[Music]
oh well by the time I was 9 or 10 I was
a earnest practitioner of ceremonial
magic and I would draw Pentacles in my
room and bird and rosemary and I was
also an altar boy at this time and it
made some problems I recall one time I
don't know how many of you are
recovering Catholics but there's a thing
which they bring out once a year I don't
know if they still do this they sort of
left the faith but they have this thing
which they use at midnight mass an
Easter called them asked for Gilliam and
it looks like a baby's rattle and you
put it in water and it has holes in the
round head and it fills with holy water
and then you can fling holy water great
distances with this thing and so one day
back in the sacristy we were cleaning
out some things and they came up the
priest came upon this old aspergillum
and I said whoa he was about to get rid
of it and I said well I have a use for
that and he said Oh what what is your
use for this my son and I said well I'm
involved in the conjuration of as IL xi
general of the mercuric sphere and it it
launched an investigation that has made
that town unsafe for the practice of
ceremonial magic to this day
but the the point of my story is they
needn't have worried because then I
don't want to step on anybody's toes but
look I'm paid to be controversial you
understand so they needn't have worried
because at least for this lumpen
Irishman
it didn't work no matter how much
rosemary I burned no matter how many wax
vigils were formed no matter how many
even more peculiar things were
undertaken it didn't seem to cut the
mustard
and then around the time that I was 14
or so I had many obsessions and my life
seems ruled by obsession and at some
point I became aware that there was a
book at the library that they didn't
want me to read this was when I was
somewhat younger and they didn't want me
to read this book and the librarian who
was friends with my mother had been told
if he asks for this book don't let him
have it so I not only determined to read
the book I determined to read every book
the author had ever written and the book
was brave new world which I don't know
how many of you have read it it wouldn't
stir a small wind these days but it did
involve all the women did wear these
prophylactic some kind of I never quite
understood what it was but it's some
kind of birth control kit that they wore
on the belt and of course people were
grown in vats and had very free sex and
so forth and so on it was an interesting
book but then I started reading the
author Aldous Huxley and I read chrome
yellow and I read antic hay and I read
after as many as summarize the Swan and
I read a fun essence and some of these
things were like screenplays and some
were comedies of British manners I kept
hoping we'd get back to the prophylactic
belt
and instead eventually I came upon the
doors of perception and read this book
and it was like it had never entered my
mind the concept of drugs intoxication
information from reflection of that sort
I mean the whole thing was just
completely puzzling to me and I can
remember following my mother around the
kitchen of our suburban home saying if
one tenth of what this guy is saying is
true this is the most amazing thing in
the world well now we know that that's a
very mild book very limited in its
claims I mean he talks about staring at
the folds of his trousers and thinking
about Hildegard von Bingen and it's
basically presented as a thought thing
and most of you look like you're
probably not old enough to remember but
there was a point in the evolution of
awareness about the psychedelic
experience where the way people did it
is they piled up art books
favorite recordings foods perfumes and
then they would get loaded and then they
would look at the art books the orange
smell the perfume it's not a bad it's
not a bad idea
[Music]
but that that was the clue to mean that
there was something going on and I was I
say I was about 14 and I had a lot ahead
of me before I really took my first trip
and I was trying to figure it out
shopping in the in the supermarket of
ideas of the time reading Camus reading
Nietzsche reading Sartre and all these
people are a huge downer as any of you
know who've read them I mean the entire
tone of modernity is just one big downer
after another you know if it's not Hana
rent on the triviality of evil well then
it's Karl Jasper's on something else or
Sartre and it's just horrible horrible
stuff well so I I became aware through
Huxley that there was this other
possibility a man and ice and Huxley
always wrote about the psychedelic
experience as a branch of the mystical
quest what he called the perennial
philosophy and so I started reading both
the scholars of mysticism such as Evelyn
Underhill and William James varieties of
the religious experience and so forth
and so on and I started reading the
primary sources Teresa of ávila Thomas
to her Jakub Burma
what's the singing Hildegard von Bingen
all of these people and and I got the
idea that there was this experience but
I couldn't find it I couldn't find it in
you know on my knees at the church for
hour after hour I mean I found various
forms of existential boredom ad
infinitum but actual and I would sit in
nature and I would hyperventilate and I
would do all these things
well the juice just wasn't coming well
to make a long story short
eventually like lots and lots of people
and by my own personal route I found my
way to these things and they are to my
mind astonishing worthy of taking risks
for because they work
I think to some degree it's true that an
all culture is somewhat unfriendly to
the individual I you know when they when
their heavy arm falls on your shoulder
and they tell you that you're going to
be sent off to some foreign hellhole to
kill people as a young man
you definitely suddenly get the notion
that culture is not your friend
but perhaps you know if you're a 12 year
old boy in an Amazonian tribe and they
announced that now it's time for the
two-week abandonment in the woods from
which if you live to tell the tale
you'll become a full member of society
I'm not sure those kids greet that the
meat of joy in their hearts it's like oh
my god now this we knew it was coming I
went through rites of passage like that
that were excruciating where I grew up
in western Colorado you weren't a real
man unless sometime between 12 and 16
you killed an elk a hunting season every
October was an excuse for this insane
rite of passage and my father was
unquestioning inhabitant of his culture
and so this was always in front of me
and when I was I guess when I was 12 I
went the first time I didn't get
anything the second year we went out and
and you know my father I sure had no
idea what a what a wilted pansy I was
in this situation because I have hid it
from my mum and I I was concerned about
all kinds of things and and eventually
this situation arose where they put me
up on this point and gave me a gun and
said if anything came by to blow it away
and you know by god this thing you know
chose to sacrifice itself as far as I
could tell I mean it did not behave at
all like L behaved it basically just
came out of the woods Stood Still I
pulled down on it closed my eyes pray
there was an enormous noise when my open
my eyes there was nothing whatsoever to
be seen I felt an enormous relief that
this thing had escaped and walked over
to find it dead as if Dorothy and
you know the oak leaves dipped in the
blood the cup of blood the whole thing I
mean I couldn't believe how out of istic
this stuff was however I never had to
please my father again I was home free
everything was forgiven from that moment
on but it brought home to me how
uncomfortable culture is and and always
has been I think
Oh
well I suppose I should make a sort of
introduction of mine myself I was born a
few months after the atom bomb was
dropped on Hiroshima as born in November
of 46 I'm a double scorpion award and
born in western Colorado and lived there
till I was 16 came to California
finished high school here went to Cal
was around Berkeley for eight or nine
years when I wasn't in Asia and I was in
Asia locked first in of the Seychelles
where I tried to emigrate emigrate then
in India
[Music]
mostly smuggling hash and buying art and
anything that became untenable I went to
Indonesia and collected butterflies for
Singapore Chinese for a while and then
taught English in Japan and and then
went to the Amazon in 71 and that trick
to the Amazon is the subject of a book I
wrote called
to true hallucinations
recently for some reason I had to lay
out my income for an attorney and say
how much I spent every month on things
like entertainment and so forth and so
on so he called me on the phone he said
you declared $15 a month for
entertainment he said based on your
income do you know how much would be a
standard deduction for entertainment and
I said how much he said $700 a month
I said that's inconceivable to me what
kind of idiot would I be if I and I said
and I put down the $15 cuz I knew you
wanted something but in fact I don't
think I spend $15 a month on
entertainment
what is entertainment anyway so you know
I I suppose it just sounds like
preaching a kind of monkey shiness but
what is the charm of all this crap can
anybody explain it to me I heard a story
about the Dalai Lama I mean let this
ricochet around in your mind the Dalai
Lama came to Los Angeles and so the
committee that was there to receive him
and make his visit comfortable wanted to
do something with him in LA that would
be uniquely la but that would be amusing
for Dali
so they decided to take him to Rodeo
Drive and and basically they just turned
him loose with his translator and said
you know we'll meet you back here in an
hour and a half and to check it out this
is a unique place in American culture
so then after it was over and they were
all having their double espresso where
the Campari or whatever they were having
the Dali Lama said I want to thank you
so much for making this experience
available to me I feel I understand
Americans so much better now I saw so
many things I wanted this is the Dali
Lama talking he saw so many things he
wanted well if the Dali Lama is not
immune my god what chance have you a
nine if the Dali Lama
can't hold this stuff back you know you
might as well buy that air may scarf
just give up give them the $200 for the
damn thing and enjoy
Carl Sagan visited me once in Hawaii but
he was more concerned to figure out
whether I really was talking to
extraterrestrials on mushrooms to his
credit he was willing to come and have a
discussion about that and also you know
I have the certitude of megalomania so
you know you don't need Carl Sagan to
tell you you're right when you have
megalomania you just confidently sit
back and wait for it all to blow your
way and you know it's worked for me over
and over in my life
it was interesting a few weeks ago I was
visited in Hawaii by none other than
Carl Sagan and he had a number of things
on his mind but one of the things that
he was at great pains to point out to me
was I said something about this
asymptotic approach to the end of
history and he said well my dear boy you
just have it all wrong
the speed of information transfer
reached the speed of light with the
invention of radio it's been absolutely
flat ever since
the largest thermal nuclear blast ever
detonated was in 1958 there hasn't been
a bigger one for 30 years the fastest
human object ever built was launched in
1967 in one sense so this nonsense about
ever increasing this that and the other
is just doesn't hold water
the genius behind banana republic wanted
to have the Travel Magazine and he
decided can you imagine a situation
where all expenses paid you grow the
world looking for the most beautiful
places and when they cut leave to get a
dollar a word and when they don't
publish what you write you get 25 cents
a word which is more than most magazines
pay when they publish
[Music]
[Music]
Richard Thailand is the source of it is
the destination in other words my friend
and he had this Thai wife so I the
problem to her and she said yes oh yes
the most degenerate people know all
about this I said well then you must
have
[Music]
and lo and behold we got samples of this
plant redstone and there was a very
hush-hush
and everyone was either depleting or or
looking at us with thin hard expressions
as we scored this plant and we do not
have to it is now growing in the line is
available for certified biochemists and
biochemical researchers to determine
what this thing is what we learn as we
made our way toward it was why it's
illegal it's illegal because it inhibits
and interferes with so who knows this is
true but say well that means you know
this is not botanically one of the great
news of the decade and explains then why
the ties are of such a ambivalent state
of mind
because it's poised like a dagger at the
heart of their economic life if it's
real
I had a very weird you know one of the
high water weirdness advance of my life
was when I was young I used to I was I
wanted the dmt flesh to last longer so I
used to smoke it at the height of LSD
trips and one Christmas vacation this
rooming house that I managed in Berkeley
had been everybody had gone home for
Christmas I thought and so I decided I
would take some LSD in Slough damn tea
and and so I took the other day and then
I smelled the DMT it was just nuts I
mean it's nuts enough but this was like
turbo charge that went on and on and on
and finally I there was a woman who I
rented a room to upstairs named rosemary
it was supposed to be in Minnesota and
she was a actress and very projective
and did everything with great flair and
she parently came back early from
Christmas vacation so she hit the front
steps running of this house and used her
key to let herself into the front door
and came right around to my door and
started beating on my door well I am by
nature a very paranoid person I mean I
couldn't be
the Rio young with kiasu in the middle
of the Amazon basin in the rainforest is
anywhere near I was in the office space
and they were screeching and chattering
and showing me all this stuff and he did
this I like I flew I jump like I feet in
the air and landed on my feet and it was
it was as though and don't try this at
home
it was as though the sudden flash of
adrenaline and the sudden movement that
I made broke up the ordinary division
between the trips and normals of our
malady or something anyway I hold the
trip with me into the room I was now
standing in the room eyes open but the
elf creatures had come with me and
everything had just been like jacked up
to some immense level of intensity and
there were these rotating geometric
things in the room hanging in the air
and it was like moving in this jerky
motion this thing is going click click
click
and it was faceted and every time it
would make this large metallic click
these plastic triangle-shaped brightly
colored chips there's something like
little pieces of a floor tile or
something would fly across the room and
each one of them had a letter on it in
an alien language sort of like Ebru or
Sanskrit and in the system there were
several of these machines and these
things were ricocheting off the walls
and I had an elf hanging off each hand
[Applause]
so I stagger over to the door fling it
back and look at her and say something
like wait do karate
yeah and she realized at that point what
my problem was
and retreated but I've never forgotten
it's the one time that is that they went
literary on me and not only did I see
them not only did I hear them but I they
were printing on the air the message as
well
very curious
[Music]
when I was schizophrenic if this is what
we're talking about my feeling about it
was and maybe this is if not true a
delusion worth playing with is I thought
aha what we call mental illness what we
call schizophrenia and what we look into
the body or the mind or the personal
history or the dream state to try and
understand and possibly cure it's not
like that at all it isn't your if you're
the person who's nuts
it isn't your problem it's something
that's happened to you not more
fundamentally than catching the flu it's
like you just happened to step in some
cosmic doodoo and now it's on the bottom
of your shoe and everybody's pointing at
you and backing up but it isn't your
fault it was just happen to be in your
path it's a kind of it's a horrible
piece of luck unless you can turn it to
your own to your own advantage and what
that means I think is obviously
integrating it well then how do you
integrate these things I think it's has
to do again a lot with where you start
from just speaking from my own personal
experience what saved me was my cynicism
that I didn't believe in anything never
had had always thought believing in
things was a bad idea
so then when this whole cosmos of
beliefs was handed to me on a platter I
just simply said maybe you know I'll act
it out but I won't I won't believe it
and I think that had I been a good
Mormon a good Catholic
good Buddhist a good something else then
I would have been lost because I would
have traded whatever it was I believed
for the new set of beliefs as it was I
just said you know what's this
beliefs I don't do that but I played
with it and somehow the playing with it
was able to deep attention it I had a
conversation with someone very recently
who by ordinary standards I think would
have to be considered nutty as a
fruitcake and you know they could hardly
speak of their condition without being
swept by an emotion that was so intense
that it reduced them to tears you know
and I said you know if you're gonna be
this nuts you should enjoy it more you
know it's two and they said you know I
am enjoying it and I said well I'm not
enjoying it because you're just
projecting such an emotional intensity
that it makes me very nervous and I
think I'm generally I speak then for the
same general masses about that what
makes it hard for the person is going
through this is that it's so hard for
other people
I mean it's freaky to be around somebody
who's crazy
[Music]
I don't you know because I'm such a
purveyor of psychedelics people are
forever leaning on me to trip with them
and I dare say you know there are people
in this room who've known me for years
and no one here can say they've ever
been seriously loaded with me because I
just don't do it I can't take it I can't
handle the feeling the feeling of risk
that permeates that that's why it amazes
me I I'm fascinated by people who have
such faith in their knowledge that that
apparent difficult situations don't
freak them out
as an example some of you know Frank
Barr he's an emergency room doctor and
I'm amazed that he can deal with people
who were dead out unconscious and just
say she'll come to in 40 minutes or so
don't worry about that when I would be
frantic I mean if I can't get a reaction
out of somebody I just go berserk and
the notion yeah I don't know whether
that's a kind of callousness therapists
are like that I mean they say you know
you come upon somebody flopping around
on the floor screaming pleading weeping
my inclination is to make them feel
better for God's sake and a therapist
would just say well they're working
through their stuff that's alright you
know how do you get that level of self
confidence where you can see somebody in
agony and say that's alright it's the
best thing for a check on them in an
hour and to see where they're at it's
awfully so I stay away from it and in my
own situation I keep people away from me
I've had many trips where I've thought
in the middle of it too thank god
there's no one here
this because if there were someone here
to see it I'm sure they would become
alarmed and decide that some crisis was
in progress and you know ultimately you
have to sort of get a kind of
perspective where you just say if I die
I die but it usually has to slam you to
the wall pretty severely to make you
turn the image I have is that I run from
it until I become so furious at this
humiliating situation that I turn and
face it and then you know if you curse
it it will step back sometimes and it's
worked every time the other thing is you
know the wonderful instinct for
equilibrium that the human mind has that
you can get pretty twisted around and if
you'll wait 24 hours 72 hours 10 days
six months it will restore to
equilibrium I'm puzzled by the cases of
permanent raving madness and I wonder
how common they are it's all messed up
in this society I mean I can show you
psychiatric residents who have never
seen an unmedicated schizophrenic in
their entire life you know because you
just they just do not encounter people
in that state what they deal with are
people who come in and been given drugs
and kept on drugs and drugs drugs drugs
that's the whole the whole dynamic
this belief that the world is entirely
independent of our minds and objective
and unaware of us is the kind of science
scientific fiction in which we operate
and then the real truth that appears to
our perceptions the truth of our
immediate experience is that the the
mind is a concentric field of
diminishing intensity that can draw
events and circumstances far from the
ranges of probability I mean I had once
I had the following experience it's all
anecdotal you see I was in a dry wash in
the Negev desert and there was
absolutely no food and I was poor
traveling hit the Machine and the cave
dweller and then there do well and it
was like a hundred and twenty degrees
outside my cave and I was sitting in
front of my cave smoking hash and out
through the shimmering heat I could see
this dot of a person and as I watched
them making their way through the rocks
and the scrub I began to have a fantasy
about this
that they had food that they didn't
simply have food that that they had
Oysters Rockefeller packed in ice that
they had Russian caviar that they had
Belgian chocolate that they had all of
this stuff and you know I haven't had a
bath in three weeks that was barely any
water in this place and this speck made
its way toward me getting larger and
larger and finally it turned into this
guy I barely knew a fellow lost soul
this was hidden southern Israel
twenty-five years ago any sit and he
came up to me and he said I have oysters
packed in ice I have Belgian chocolate I
and he had gotten a job dishwashing that
morning at the King David hotel and had
just quit in disgust halfway through the
day and had raided this super fancy
four-star hotel and just had a backpack
full of this stuff and I didn't even
bother to tell him what am I gonna say
you know I mean sure of course
so these kinds of things
and they're very private you see nothing
happens there except that a guy quits
his job and rips off a hotel except that
it is coincident with an internal state
a private musing of somebody else and
when the two things come together the
coincidence of it is absolutely
excruciating
[Music]
I was in London a few weeks ago and at a
party and I was the guest of honor and
they brought out last year's Welsh
mushrooms and made a big tea for
everybody and the hostess said you know
it's it's just it's just almost like a
gesture I mean there are so many of us
and so few mushrooms but we'll each just
get a little bit well so I was first out
of the chute and you know I was I don't
know whether it all pooled on the top in
one place what was going on but you know
I just sat down on the ground and this
guy who said is some person of great
reputation who said he'd wanted to meet
me for years and years was sitting in
front of me trying to get to know me and
and finally he just said he said you're
flaming aren't you and I said yes I
can't carry on this conversation I just
have to hold on to the grass well I
don't know what all this means I don't
want to become afraid of it and I blame
myself I don't think the thing has a
negative edge unless you've somehow come
out of jiggle with it and I don't know
whether that means you know it what does
it mean if it becomes harder and harder
to take these things does it mean you're
getting out of balance does it mean
you're just getting older where should
the blame be put and then what can you
do about it the only thing I found to do
about it is stop running and turn and
face it but each time I do that it seems
to require the very limit of my courage
and I don't know how long one's courage
laughs maybe it's not a bad thing I mean
after all people who climb mountains
like Mount Everest
they don't do it till their dying day at
some point they you know knock off and
become a consultant
that's where a manufacturer or something
he at times appeared to work miracles at
one point I I was trying to test him and
his abilities and I recall that there
was a box that my grandfather had given
me that you opened with a little silver
key that had been lost for years and
years and he I said well if you can do
anything
why don't you produce the key that to
that box which neither of us had seen
even the box for a dozen years by this
time he was naked and locked in a room
at the mission and and he went in he
would make these bizarre gestures these
strange archit I don't know what was
going on and he he went into a period of
concentration gave a wild squawk and
slammed into my hand and gave me the key
gave me the key he was naked he had been
locked in this room for 14 days at that
time and I was like I didn't know what
was going on but what was happening to
me was I was like utterly unconcerned
for his mental health or any practical
concern which was causing a lot of
problems for the other people on the
expedition in classical psychology this
is called a date a parlay I do a
delusion of - it's a simultaneous
schizophrenic episode it usually
involves a mother and a daughter I've
never heard of a brother brother while a
I do but it was accompanied by all these
exterior manifestations freak rainbows
and in my case an encounter with a UFO
and this UFO encounters had a very
curious quality to it not that they
don't always
but this was even more curious than the
pedestrian UFO encounter what happened
was it was on the fort it was on the
thirteenth day of the reversal and that
I had had this intimation there was
something going on about the Southwest I
wasn't clear quite what it was in the
the two women on the expedition were
that afternoon washing our clothes down
by the choro by the lake and I looked
across the lake and I saw in the sky not
a rainbow but just a spot in the sky
that was a spectra Grammatik diffraction
you know a little patch of rainbow and I
asked the women if they saw it and they
said they didn't and then it intensified
and by this time I was plenty in the
doghouse as well I mean this has put a
great deal of strain on our small party
as you can imagine and this Spectre
dramatic irid Jewell intensified and
then I said to them now do you see it
and they looked and they said oh yeah
mmm it's in a big deal not much but I
knew I knew
and knowing means the voice was speaking
to me all kinds of weird things went on
I mean I discovered that I that the
closer I was to water the easier it was
for me to rhyme at which I never and
then years later I encountered the
Celtic saying poetry is made at the edge
of running water and and the thing would
give me these aphorisms like one time it
said the Clones lowered is a stoned mode
and you know and I was not sleeping I
was now 11 days without sleep so that
night I decided to sit by the choro and
just because I stayed up all night and I
would walk in the fields and the thing
would
draw the would connect up the
constellations for me and show me where
they were in the sky there was also
embedded in all this thing the
intimation of this thing called the
teacher which was a giant insect-like
thing that was always like right over
here and there was the sense of
something watching us from the sky
something moving us very very gently but
persistently toward this very weird
breakthrough
[Music]
one of the hardest evenings I ever spent
was that combination and I will never do
that again but I haven't been able to
line up too much support the question is
what about combining Pugin harmala with
mushrooms with stir fara cubensis now
what happened to me was I took half a
dose of mushrooms which for me would be
two and a half grams I took two and a
half grams of mushrooms with half a dose
of ayahuasca and it was it was seemed
crazy-making to me very very very
unpleasant State I was I think what was
happening as I analyzed it later was
that short-term memory absolutely would
not transcript and so I got into this
strange loop which went like this
something's wrong what's wrong
nothing's wrong okay
something's wrong
what's wrong nothing's wrong okay and it
it was get it was serious and it went on
for about an hour and I I just did not
know what to do i I had the image from
2001 of the guy outside the ship saying
open the pod door is how saying I can't
do that
open the pod door is how I'm sorry Dave
and it really seemed to me I could
almost see an enzymatic I almost had
like a nano engineer's view of the
problem I could see it the synaptic
level that the molecular machinery was
lodged in some peculiar configuration
and and I just and I you just I was
broke into a sweat and I and I just said
okay I'm going to sit here until this
goes away I'm not going to start
screaming I'm not going to call for help
I'm not going to do anything I'm just
going to wait until this goes away and
then I started deep breathing as a
strategy for metabolizing and after 45
minutes or so it kind of jiggled loose
and then it was like oh wow what a
bummer that was
[Music]
[Music]
kath and I were in the Amazon in 76
taking ayahuasca we got in with this
certain group of people in Peru that
took it every week and you know cultures
have different ways of handling hassle
and in some cultures it's
confrontational in other cultures not
the way these Peruvian country folk
operated was if somebody was screwing up
nobody would ever say so they would just
talked about these people behind their
back until the Morpho genetic field of
gossip was so strong that you would
basically awaken to the problem so there
was a complex social situation going on
in this ayahuasca circle which was there
was a master shaman who we were
apprenticed to who was beloved by his
neighborhood but he had a nephew a
sobrino who was a jerk I mean this guy
was as Don Fidel said ambitious he dealt
a little weed he did a little pimping he
was just sort of an edger on any type of
guy and every Saturday night we would
all get together and take ayahuasca
about 30 of us older shamans are guy
people from the neighborhood and this
sobrino Don Jose so I don't know what
the real history of it was because I
have just arrived on the scene but these
old guys would sing these echoes these
magical songs on ayahuasca that appear
as colored tapestries in front of your
eyes
and you know they were they had soul
they were into it they were and this guy
would sing against them I mean it's the
ruh this thing you can possibly imagine
I mean imagine if if you know Lou Reed
we're trying to give her performance and
the guy in the third row just launched
into old man
and you know I mean in this town I'm
sure large guys would appear and say sir
in Peru it didn't work like that
they just kept singing he kept singing
and it was clear that this is how it was
gonna be handled that we had just
divided into two separate entities here
well my wife was sitting next to me and
he was sitting across the room from us
the sobrino and I had been watching him
for a long time and I was loaded to the
gills and I could see he would get up on
his haunches and he he looked like a
monkey he he his face it was uncanny I
mean he looked like a monkey and he also
looked kind of like a jackal a dog with
long teeth kept going through these
changes and and Kathleen Dover to me and
said something like the skies of [ __ ]
woman I just said you know let it slide
what do we know think of it as
anthropology he she wasn't having it so
after a while he kept doing this and at
one point and everybody in the room
every person in the room was bummed out
and they were looking at their laughs
all eye contact was broken it's actually
when I was a kid I invented a word the
word is fard ow and it means the
embarrassment you feel when someone else
[ __ ] up you know and you happen to just
be there but somehow the aura that is so
strong the entire room is just a wash
and farted out and the old guys are
singing and the guy is singing so then
at the end of a particularly intense
clash of these two styles my wife just
looked across the room at this guy and
like put a whammy on him and I saw these
red arrows leave her eyes and like like
dotted lines
and they move fairly slowly you know
more slowly than you could throw a ball
or something will win this line of red
arrows got to this guy he was knocked
off his feet he fell backwards with his
legs in the air and there was a big
noise and all the singing stopped and
everybody in the room looked up and
these three old shaman who were sitting
behind Don Fidel who I to that point had
not heard speak any language but Quechua
one turn to the other and he says in
Spanish oh the gringa sends this
[Laughter]
I had an experience earlier this summer
which I probably shouldn't tell but I
will that is an example of how it gets
weird we had we a friend of mine moved
to London and left me his library for
unspecified amounts of time to keep a
very bizarre library mostly platonic
stuff a lot of magic a lot of that sort
of thing and so we built a book loft for
it and our house is wedge-shaped and so
this book loss is way up at the top of
the house and I was alone in the house
and I took seven dried grams and I was
sitting there and it was just beginning
to come on I was in the show what you
know thing phase and it was beginning to
show what it knew and there was this
disrupted area of space in front of me
where it was like rotating and I was
looking into it and talking it up and I
was actually speaking at first I was
just speaking in my mind then I would
began speaking aloud and I was saying
you are a beautiful thing you are
beautiful and suddenly there things
changed and it became very cold and
meaning the temperature fell suddenly
and the dog next door who never howls
how old and the cat which was down below
me and I was up in this loft looking
down at our bed the cat was on the bed
the cat flared out and made this really
weird noise and I just you know I
stopped what I was doing and projected
my mind into this situation and at that
moment I heard this sound which was like
and then something settled on to the
roof sufficient to make the six by
fourteen inch beam
creak in just swing and I was floored
and I just I just sat for a minute and I
was not frightened in fact my emotion
was hard to get back to but I wasn't
frightened but just at that moment these
this thing was really coming on and
really visually peculiar and it seemed
like the two things were independent the
trip was getting stronger and stronger
but a 10-ton something had landed on a
roof beam of my house so I just sat with
it for about 30 seconds and then this
thought or voice came and it was this
thing has come because of something I'm
doing and that means that I can get rid
of it so I just turned like this up
toward the roof and projected this
thought very strongly which was begone I
am in conversation with an elder and
this thing went and there was a long
pause 10 seconds or so and then whatever
it was it lifted off the roof and went
away and what was weird about this was I
had never I had never ever used in my
own mind this phrase an elder to
describe the mushroom it was like just
came out of me
and the whole episode seemed real weird
to me and I just let it ride but that's
an instance where you know there is this
let's call it synchronicity so that we
don't have to believe that a pterodactyl
does mine run there is this
synchronicity for some reason there
chose to be a fluttering sound and the
beam chose to creat now doubtless this
has to do with temperature and the
cooling of day to night
but you know it was a thing to go
through
[Music]
this is my ending story for the
afternoon
I don't present it as a summation but it
amuses me for those of you who don't
like Jewish jokes you won't notice as
this joke is told that it is easily
translated into a Zen mode a Sufi mode I
just like the Jewish flavor there were
two rabbis extremely advanced high
rabbis Talmud is great men of
accomplishment and they were at Temple
and one of them prayed and he said Lord
he stood up and he spoke aloud and he
said Lord I am nothing and then he sat
down and the other guy got up and he
said Lord I am nothing and there was a
guy there sweeping the floor custodial
person and he thought well people are
praying got a prayer in here so he stood
up and said Lord I'm nothing
and the first rabbi looked at the second
rabbi and he said so look who thinks
he's nothing
that's it that's a story about the
imagination
I grew up in western Colorado and we
prided ourselves on being Westerners
every time I come south I realized that
the place where I grew up was south but
like schizoid about it and never owned
up to the fact that the psychology of
North Carolina is more what western
Colorado is about than the psychology of
Southern California by any stretch
anyway not to wander I grew up in this
place and I was curious and I think
curiosity is the psychedelic virtue it's
the precondition for finding your way
into the presence of this answer
intellectual curiosity and I was told
well you know there were dinosaurs here
a hundred million years ago and 50
million years before that there was an
ocean here and we would go out into the
dry arroyos and sandstone country and
here would be these seashells and and
spiral ammonites and stuff and I was
obsessed with the sea because I had
never seen it I didn't see the ocean
until I was 14 years old and yet here
with evidence of the ocean in some of
the driest and most shattered desert
country you could ever see and so I if I
got the message and the message is the
world is not what it appears to be where
there are deserts one finds evidence of
oceans where there are wastelands one
finds evidence of jungles and by
extension where there is love one can
uncover animosity and conflict where
there is hate one can uncover love and
community so very early I got the notion
things are not
they appear to be
[Music]